hello everybody
welcome to our session and today we're
going to be talking about how how to
enhance your security posture and run
pci compliant application
with anthus i'm harish jayakumar i lead
the application modernization team here
at google cloud
and today with me i have pan hi i'm anne
wallace
security solution manager with google
cloud
thank you man let's jump in so when we
talk about
running regulated workloads it can get
quite complex
especially because there are multiple
stakeholders that are involved in it on
one side you have the makers that's the
developers the product owners and the
enterprise architects
and on the other side you have the
checkers which are the security teams
risk and compliance team and the legal
teams as well
so because of these complexities
regulated workloads are the slowest ones
to move to the cloud
or even to modernize so in this talk
you're going to be exploring how to
modernize these workloads
at the same time meet the compliance
requirements either natively on google
cloud
or if you want to run them on-prem using
anthos
now running a regulated workload
especially for pci in this case we were
talking about for this one
is challenging because audits can be
quite daunting
why one compliance frameworks were not
built for cloud native architectures
two it actually takes a village to pass
an audit to demonstrate the compliance
associated with it and then three you
want to also avoid misconfigurations and
if
there are any you have to fix them and
then finally
evidencing a shared responsibility
especially today when we talk with
customers most of them either have a
hybrid model or they are on multiple
clouds
so understanding that shared
responsibility becomes very very
important
which brings you to this slide over here
how does this fit into the shared
responsibility model
so when we're looking at simply for
example running antos on google cloud
or if you're running antos on-prem you
can see the difference over there
simply running on and pass cloud you see
a lot of it is actually handled to you
by google itself and the customer only
needs to focus on the application
some configuration associated with that
and some base images
whereas the picture completely changes
when you move to anthony's on-prem
there's much more control the customer
has to take care of meeting the known
hardware the networking the storage and
the physical hosting
so we need to be able to see for example
if something happens
something goes wrong who's responsible
for it let's take example for example
when an identity management is done
to whereas on the google cloud you can
actually leverage the google cloud
identity in some form or the other with
cloud iam
and then we can handle that for you so
customers are starting to adopt anthos
to build the next generation digital
platforms
modernizing the security for cloud
native deployments is a great use case
why
they're actually using it and the key
objectives for these modernizations
are one increasing the developer
productivity through the use of
containers and microservices
while adopting hybrid and multi-cloud as
deployment platforms
now many of these customers processes
sensitive data that include pii pci and
phi
further they must also meet their
regulatory compliance
but as application teams adopt new
technology stacks and development
processes
using the existing paradigms and
processes is no longer optimal or even
sufficient
so in order to deliver the developer
agility the security
stack also needs to evolve to align with
the new development and rollout
processes
it must also address new threats that
apply to modern production environments
now let's pivot quickly to compliance
requirements so we've taken some of the
compliance frameworks
such as nist 853 which maps to fed ram
pci dss iso 27001
and have identified some common
technical requirements
they actually fall into these five
categories
segmentation isolation identity access
management data security supply chain
application security
now we don't have time to drive into all
these 20 in this 25 minutes talk but we
will talk about how anthos can help
with several of these requirements right
out of the box as you can see the same
five requirements
we've later done we put them down into
five pillars and out of the box
anthous offers a lot of security
capabilities
each control aligns with the common
compliance requirements that we talked
about in the previous slide whether it's
going to be segmentation networking
iam data security and encryption secure
supply chain and application security
so as you can see most of these features
to help you achieve your security
posture
but as i mentioned before it's the
shared responsibility model
and you need to know how to blend the
controls together appropriately and
understand what you are responsible for
for that what we're going to be
introducing is anthony's blueprints
and to talk in detail about that i'd
like to call back and
and cool thanks harish
so before we dive into the anthos
blueprints first let's talk about our
security blueprint so we've designed
security blueprints to help some of this
complexity that uh harish described
to simplify it so the first security
blueprint we have is called
security posture so this is a collection
of resources and code that
deliver granular and specific security
postures to a workload such as maybe a
customer-facing application or back-end
process
for example securing data or securing
api endpoints
the next one that we offer is called a
landing zone so this is a pre-configured
environment with a standard set of
secure cloud infrastructure
policy and guidelines so this can be
something that's otherwise very
complicated to set up it might take
months of investigation
implementation by trial and error to get
right the first time so an example this
is pci for anthos
regardless of the type of security
blueprint they're all designed to be
easy to use and deploy
and we also employ all of google cloud
security best practices in the blueprint
so you can say they're secure
by default so one of the first security
landing zones that we we released was
pci
on gke and coming soon is pci on anthos
so these help customers get started
with compliance on anthos quicker so it
also allows you to quickly and easily
deploy workloads on anthos
that align to pci dss and repeatable
supported and secure ways so let's look
at everything that's included in the
blueprint
so the pci and anthony's blueprint
contains many opinionated reference
architecture diagrams
depicting the infrastructure and
application deployments while they're
intended to be used with deployable
assets
they actually show you how to create
diagrams of your containerized card
holder data environments
and the boundaries between pci and
non-pci workloads
which is a requirement in pci audits the
blueprint also contains different
deployable assets
and then we also include pci dss 3.2.1
mappings to the solutions
and a compliance white paper
so with our anthos on gcp blueprint we
provide you with terraform templates to
set up your
infrastructure these include org
policies projects vpcs and gke clusters
and as harish described about the shift
in the shared responsibility model
our on-prem we only provide you with
reference architectures for squares one
and two
but with both of the blueprints we
provide you with service mesh profiles
gke configurations
acm policies and then a demo app to test
out the environment
configuration and setup
so let's pivot to segmentation there are
two types of segmentation
so the first one is macro segmentation
so these are things that you do inside
or outside the cluster so you segment
the users
networks and applications using
different google cloud
features and tools this really helps you
set aside the scope
of the audit and then we have micro
segmentation so these are things that
you do inside the cluster so let's
double click on that a little bit
so with gke micro segmentation we offer
many ways to do this so we have network
policies this this helps with layer 3
and 4
network level segmentation then we have
gke name spaces for virtual clusters to
segment teams or maybe app versus
prod or app dev versus prod then we have
gke
private clusters so you have clusters
with private ip space and then antho
service mesh
but the net net here is there are many
ways to do micro segmentation in a
cluster
so for the pci on anthos on-prem
blueprint the first layer of
segmentation is addressed through
separate clusters
so we create two clusters two user
clusters one for in scope
or for your card holder data cluster and
then one for the out of scope workloads
and then building upon the segmentation
we have segmented out of the pods within
a cluster but
you further need to demonstrate
separation of maybe dev and test versus
prod environments to your auditor
or you need to segment application
profiles so this is where you would use
different name spaces
and then oftentimes you're presented
with a requirement to protect the
routing information and the private ip
spaces
this is where you mark a cluster as
private in such a cluster
and the master become inaccessible from
the public internet
and then the nodes in the private
cluster do not have public ip
addresses and so the admin and user
clusters are private for the on-prem
blueprint and the gcp blueprint
so looking at some of the reference
architectures that are provided as part
of this blueprint
you can see here that again the end
scope and out of scope cluster
separation and then we have antho
service mesh so it's a single mesh for
multi-clusters and then our demo app is
called online boutique so this
is an e-commerce micro services demo
application so this allows you to test
out the controls in the architecture
the pci dss audit burden is minimized by
moving the microservices
from that demo application that don't
touch payment card
data into the out of scope cluster this
reference architecture
details this layout this also helps you
with your own architectures and
documentation
and then looking more specifically at
pci requirements so pci requirement 4
talks about
encrypting data in flight specifically
of card holder data across open and
public networks
for our on-prem blueprint the in-scope
and out-of-scope clusters are in
separate networks which helps with
strong isolation for pci boundaries
this also means that the cross-cluster
communication must go through an istio
gateway
all cross customer communication uses
mutual tls
authentication and encryption citadel is
also included for managing the internal
certificates
so a lot of the blueprint is for day
zero but we also want to talk about
day one and day two sort of scenarios so
this is where policies code or shifting
left
happens so you wanna you know setting up
initially is great
everything's pci compliant but as you're
deploying new containers or new code
into your environment how do you make
sure
these um meet pci requirements so to
help with this
we have binary authorization anthos
config management
and anthos policy controller so let's
look at these in a little bit more
detail
so for a requirement such as establish a
process to identify security
vulnerabilities
you can use container registry
vulnerability scanning
so this checks the images that you push
into the registry for known security
vulnerabilities
it is constantly refreshing its
vulnerability database by ingesting
corresponding vendor security feeds
so that you can be notified of new
vulnerabilities that may be a
affected scan containers you can also
tie this in with pub sub to get
notifications
so you can integrate this in with your
ci cd process or file
bugs for newly discovered
vulnerabilities
and another requirement is in to ensure
all systems and software are protected
from known vulnerabilities this is where
binary authorization can help
so it ensures that only properly signed
containers are deployed into production
or other environments
you can use binary authorization to
create deployment policies based on
container image metadata
so these policies can be based on
attestation such as vulnerability scan
or other types of signatures such as
maybe being built by a particular
pipeline or having gone through a
specific qa process
again this ensures that only trusted
images are deployed into your
environment
so let's put all this together so when
code is checked into github or your
source code repository it triggers a
build in cloud build
cloud build then generates a new
container image it
will create a build record of the
contain that contains information on the
image including the location
the source code from which the image was
built
and then that triggers a vulnerability
scan so the vulnerability scan is done
the results of that scan are stored as
part of the metadata for that container
and as mentioned on the previous slide
you can configure binary authorization
to require attestations based on the
vulnerability scan results
so this prevents images with known
vulnerabilities beyond a certain level
so maybe say hi
from being deployed you can also have
other requirements like only allowing
images from trusted sources
so if someone tries to deploy one of
these unauthorized images binary
authorization will stop it
and all of this is logged in cloud audit
log
so now anthony's config management or
acm
so with acm you can create common
configurations across
all your infrastructure including custom
policies and apply it to both on-prem
and across clouds anthos config
management evaluates to changes and
rolls them out to all the kubernetes
clusters so that your desired state is
always reflected
and so based on open policy agents
gateway acm policy controller provides
first-class integration between
opa and kubernetes via custom controller
so this turns rego policies into
kubernetes objects allowing them to be
customized and deployed using your
standard workflows
when policy controller is configured
incoming objects can be
denied emission into your cluster or
audited to see if they violate
governance policies
so we offer quite a few sample policies
that you can use with acm they include
policies like requiring services to
disable
unauthorized access or label enforcement
but more specifically with our anthos
pci blueprints we include policies to
help enforce tls and again
this helps enforce pci requirement for
which talks about
encrypting data in transit specifically
of card holder data
across open and public networks
so as you can see from this slide
looking at some other
common controls we can see how services
like binary authorization
or policy controller and anthos config
management can help
and then lastly we tie all of this
together by mapping the various
components and policies
in the blueprint to pci dss 3.2.1
and we also include a pci white paper so
the white paper provides an independent
third-party assessment of the blueprint
performed by pci auditors
this not only gives you our customers
more confidence in our solution
it is also something that you can
provide your qsa as part of your audit
which hopefully will help speed up your
assessment
so to learn more about this um or our
other blueprint schedule a session with
your
google team or check out the links here
so there's one for
google cloud and pci and one for our
security blueprints
thank you